diese bedrohung im web wird immer größer
im internet sind nicht nur echte user
sondern auch immer mehr automatisierte
programme unterwegs die großen schaden
anrichten die sogenannten bettbezügen
betrügen und manipulieren und richten
damit nicht nur im ecommerce enormen
schaden an einer aktuellen studie
zufolge werden sie immer komplexer und
vor allem auch immer schwerer zu
erkennen neben einem enormen
wirtschaftlichen schaden den sie
verursachen bergen sie auch noch eine
andere gefahr kriegs und science im
future geht es montags mittwochs und
freitags spannendes science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpassen sie nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen
dieses video ist in zusammenarbeit mit
dem magazin für professionelle
informationstechnik entstanden und am
ende gibt es ein exemplar für euch
kostenlos beziehungsweise hierunter mich
schaut mal nach youtube videos online
shopping news und soziale medien wir
alle verursachen täglich jede menge
traffic im web aber der anteil des web
traffic sehr durch uns user also durch
echte menschen verursacht wird ist nur
ein kleiner teil des gesamten traffics
etwa 55 bis 65 prozent davon wird durch
sogenannte bots eine kurzform für robots
verursacht also durch programme die ohne
menschliches zutun automatisiert
aktionen im web durch für normale bots
sind für webseiten etwas gutes dazu
gehören zb google bot den content von
webseiten sichten damit man diese
letztendlich über die suchmaschine
finden kann oder bots die preise aus
online-shops auslesen und diese an
vergleichsportale übergeben diese guten
bots machen etwa 35 bis 40 prozent des
gesamten web traffics aus also so viel
wie wir menschlichen user aber wenn es
gute mods gibt es dann gibt es eben auch
schlechte bot so genannte bett bots die
machen die restlichen 20 bis 30 prozent
des traffics aus und haben negative
auswirkungen auf webseiten diese
gefährlichen automatisierten agenten
attackieren webseiten auf der
applikationsebene solche cyber angriffe
werden genutzt um konkurrenz unternehmen
im web zu schaden oder profit zu machen
bei ecommerce funktioniert das zum
beispiel so die checken im großen stil
die angebote auf webseiten und kaufen
begrenzte angebote bevor es echte
tun können besonders bei knappen
produkten die begrenzten reise
kontingenten oder limitierten sneakern
da konkurrieren die bots mitmenschen und
meistens gewinnen sie weil sie um ein
vielfaches schneller sind die betreiber
der box können die waren dann
weiterverkaufen und das mit einem
saftigen aufpreis oder vielleicht nicht
ganz so bett sie holen einfach nur im
großen stil informationen zur
preisentwicklung bestimmter produkte ein
damit händler immer den günstigsten
preis anbieten können
auf diese fragwürdige techniker hatten
sogar web riesen wie amazon zurück
besonders betroffen sind airlines und
online wettbüros daneben gibt es auch
bots die komplette webseiten und shops
kopieren damit user sich dann in den
nachgeahmten falschen shops registrieren
dadurch erhalten sie deren log-in-daten
und füttern damit wiederum andere bots
die versuchen sich mit den login-daten
bei etlichen anderen portalen ein zu
locken und auf kosten der user betrug zu
begehen
auch bei großen datenlecks kommen band
bots zum einsatz auch hier wird mit
ihrer hilfe mit den gelegten daten
betrogen und darunter leiden nicht nur
die user auch die betroffenen anbieter
sind oft monate lang damit beschäftigt
das chaos wieder in den griff zu
bekommen
mal ganz abgesehen von der negativen pr
die das image eines webshops oder einer
plattform auf lange zeit schädigen kann
auch in der werbung richten bednorz
immensen schaden an online werbung wird
von den werbetreibenden auf pro klick
bezahlt wenn also bots darauf
programmiert sind unendlich oft auf eine
bestimmte anzeige zudem wird es für den
anbieter richtig teuer
ohne das echte kunden auf seiner seite
gelandet wären manchmal verursachen bots
auch einfach so viele anfragen bis der
server einer webseite dem nicht mehr
standhält und die seite so lahm gelegt
wird und ganz nebenbei verfälschen die
programme mit ihrem traffic die
statistik die online fast immer
grundlage von analysen und schließlich
auch strategischen entscheidungen sind
und noch ein thema bei dem sie uns alle
betreffen und wirklich schlimme folgen
haben sie sorgen für stimmung in
sozialen netzwerken und beeinflussen so
die meinung von unzähligen usocial bots
nutzen dafür die algorithmen der
netzwerke aus und treiben diskussionen
an die ohne sie vielleicht gar keine
geworden wären sie verbreiten und
beantworten inhalte mit bestimmten
hashtags um diese inhalte für mehr
nutzer sichtbar zu machen
je mehr user ein thema sehen und damit
interagieren desto größer wird die
chance dass sie zum trend werden und
vielleicht
sogar von den medien und politikern
aufgegriffen werden über solche bots
wurde erstmals während des ukraine
konflikts von journalisten berichtet und
während der flüchtlingskrise sah man sie
immer öfter ihren höhepunkt hatten die
bots wohl während des us wahlkampfes bei
dem sie zu regelrechten wahlhelfer
geworden sind forschende aus den usa
fanden heraus dass sowohl donald trump
als auch eli clinton damals auf facebook
und twitter
große unterstützung durch die
versteckten programm erhalten haben
eigentlich ist ja eine der
errungenschaften des internets dass
einzelne menschen eine stimme erhalten
und als masse ihre wünsche und nöte
kundtun können
das macht das web eigentlich zu einem
großartigen demokratischen tool
eigentlich der mit hilfe von bots wird
im netz ganz offensichtlich betrogen und
gefakte diskussionen und trends erzeugt
dabei reichen wohl schon wenige bots aus
die automatisiert botschaften verbreiten
um die stimmung in sozialen medien
deutlich zu beeinflussen
das zeigt eine studie der uni
duisburg-essen die kürzlich im european
journal of information systems
veröffentlicht wurde für die studie
wurde ein virtuelles experiment
durchgeführt dafür haben die forschenden
ein netzwerk mit 1000 virtuellen
akteuren simuliert die annahme war dass
die ursprünglichen meinungen zu einem
thema zu 50 prozent positiv und zu 50
prozent negativ sind laut dem
studienleiter boss gewinnt in der hälfte
der fälle eine seite die oberhand wenn
keine bots mitdiskutieren hier kommt die
theorie der schweigespirale ins spiel
die besagt dass viele menschen weniger
bereit sind ihre meinung öffentlich zu
machen wenn sie dem eingeschätzten
meinungsklima widerspricht wenn es also
so scheint das in einem sozialen
netzwerk die mehrheit der user anderer
meinung sind traut man sich eher nicht
sich zu äußern deswegen hat das
forschungsteam untersucht wie potts eine
solche spirale auslösen können man fand
heraus dass schon bots etwa zwei bis
vier prozent ausreichen um andere user
in einer kontroversen diskussion zum
schweigen zu bringen
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass sich die von
den robotern unterstützte seite
durchsetzt steigt dadurch von 50 auf 66
prozent weil ein falscher eindruck zur
stimmungslage entsteht wie gut diese
täuschung funktioniert hängt vor allem
von drei faktoren ab wie viele
verbindungen gibt es zwischen den
nutzern eines netzwerks werden die bots
darin zentral platziert agieren sie
sowie echte menschen aktuell
kann man die social spots noch erkennen
weil sie noch nicht perfekt programmiert
sind doch das wird mit der zeit
passieren und dann befürchten die
forscher nennen das die software roboter
eine echte gefahr für die demokratie
werden könnten schon jetzt gibt es
programme die nur schwer als solche
identifizierbar sind komplexe box können
das verhalten echter nutzer sehr gut
nachahmen dafür folgen sie selbstständig
anderen usern posten zum teil belanglose
dinge und können manchmal sogar schon
richtige unterhaltung mit anderen echten
nutzern führen die studie ist natürlich
nur ein theoretisches modell ohne echte
menschen und ohne echte soziale
netzwerke inwieweit die ergebnisse auf
echte soziale interaktionen im netz
übertragbar sind muss noch erforscht
werden dass solche sozialen bots bereits
im einsatz sind steht aber außer frage
und oftmals verbreiten sie hoch
politische inhalte
das ist wirklich gefährlich weil
aufgrund von gefälschten
stimmungsbildern in den sozialen medien
wichtige entscheidungen getroffen werden
um herauszufinden ob man es in einem
netzwerk mit einem bus zu tun hat gibt
es zumindest ein paar merkmale auf die
man achten kann die programme verstecken
sich häufig hinter untypischen
profilbildern die keine fotos echter
leute zeigen und wenn doch dann sind es
auf menschen aus dem aktuellen
zeitgeschehen meistens sind es
industrielle comic avatare oder bunte
grafiken und in den profilbildern sind
oft schon politische botschaften
enthalten
man sollte sich auf jeden fall die
inhalte anschauen die einen account
geteilt hat da sieht man oft schon sehr
schnell dass vor allem fake news seiten
wie private blogs mit radikalen
positionen geteilt werden und kaum links
zu bekannten vertrauenswürdigen medien
außerdem kann man beobachten wie ein
vermeintlicher user auf fragen im
zusammenhang reagiert wenn er ausreicht
und nur mit floskeln reagiert handelt es
sich vermutlich um einen social bot das
ist wahrscheinlich auch der fall wenn
die antworten eins zu eins an mehrere
nutzer versendet werden
es ist schon erschreckend dass dem
menschlichen traffic von 40% ein bett
bot traffic von 20% gegenüber steht und
noch erschreckender ist es dass viele
online anbieter noch nicht mal mit
solchen angriffen rechnen weshalb die
bots oft auf kaum oder gar keinen
widerstand treffen selbst die großen
anbieter sind davor nicht gefeit erst im
januar hat der test spacex chef elon
musk tipps dazu an jack dorsey gegeben
den chef von twitter
er hat dem empfohlen die plattform noch
besser darauf zu programmieren bots von
echten usern zu unterscheiden um
manipulationsversuche vorzubeugen
zum glück sind einige bots tatsächlich
leicht zu erkennen und lassen sich über
statistisch regeln einfach und
automatisiert aussperren aber wenn die
programme das verhalten echter menschen
imitieren wird es schon schwieriger sie
aus zu sperren wie man es als
administrator schafft solche box mit
einfachen methoden zu entdecken und wie
man sich dagegen schützen kann erfahrt
ihr im fachmagazin ix dort findet ihr
auch andere umfassend recherchierte
themen aus dem bereich von it security
über big data bis hin zu embedded
systems also exklusiv für euch klicks
zum zuschauer und zuschauerinnen gibt es
jetzt eine digitale ausgabe gratis
kriegt dafür einfach auf diesen link
oder unten in die beschreibung und es
lohnt sich auf jeden fall hammer magazin
bis dann bleibt dran